this shouldn't extra water we will see
it's gonna start wide and then you see
you first do then it actually needs the
dough when you do it okay
a to ground deficit as wide as possible
I usually start a / yes released a
theater for school yeah
so put your pasta geography fictitious
like this that one like target daily
fresh you know what my mother so by the
way area that's funny huh
we will need to sprinkle machine
otherwise it thanks to stick yeah and
this is afterwards you'll acknowledge to
make the tiger tell you better day
once you know what this way
it's adorable pick out what we're trying
to do their character their other kind
of fast stuff that we're making we skip
the step here which will be at the pasta
okay it's easier to watch a past arrest
we just have to keep rolling
and then you just try to squeeze it a
little bit more and you leave that or
it's just a shape you want to flatten it
if you want to keep it rough yeah but
you see okay okay
something like this and then you put
them to dry upside down
well you let the bastards
I know
yeah we can also leave the patient yes
it's absolutely fine
and and then we also created a little
bit of pecorino cheese
Oliver's eye and we just let it rest and
somewhere with the pasta ready we must
double checks and
like the scrap pieces we do
what you call your mother
that yaki and so what does mal a yachty
brightly kind of pasta can you invite
the supermarket supervisor discount so
especially when you use the rolling you
you might have a lot of pieces but you
just make my advantage a few any to make
much faster you can give increases for
about 10 minutes then we drained I'm not
super one we want to keep a little bit
of the water and then once we drain them
in our
member